[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous part of the lecture we
had
given some of the motivating background
of
cutting calculus of variations and we
had uh discussed
uh certain dangers or
uh certain initial temptations one may
have in proceeding with
uh minimizations or maximizations
in general extremization of uh
integrations
and we had uh and the point where we had
left off in the
in the previous lecture was that we
wanted to
go back to the basics of how we
arrive at the method of minimizing or
maximizing
a simple function as we used to do in
differential calculus
so we go back we want to go back
beyond the algorithmic wave which we all
which we are all familiar with
and take a relook at the method
which led to that algorithm of finding
the
minimization of maximization of
functions so
uh with the with the motivation that
we'll be able to export the same kind of
idea
to what we require uh for integrations
okay so uh
the topic we want to explore here is
extremization of functions
basically what we are going to do here
is
uh is effectively a a recap
of what you learned in your high school
okay so maybe in your plus two
the extremization of functions so
we consider a function y is equal to f
of x
and we say that uh
like if we understand how to do
minimization the same kind of thing will
be
applicable for maximization up in
general for extremization
so we say that suppose
uh suppose
suppose f of x
is it takes on a minimum value
at x equal to a
so uh what is the basic method
behind the algorithm behind the
algorithm
of saying that f dash x is equal to 0
at x equal to a and then to say
that f double dash of x is greater than
0
at x equal to a for f of x to be minimum
at x equal to a we know that we know
what to do with that
with the derivations the know the method
but what is the motivation behind that
method
okay to understand that what we are
going to do is we are going to tailor
expand this
okay so this f of x we are going to
tailor expand like this
about the point of concern which is x
equal to a
when i write f dash a what i basically
mean is that
i am doing df dx and then evaluating it
at x equal to a i i hope uh
nobody will face a problem with this
notation
proceeding further we have x minus
a whole square divided by factorial 2
then second derivative
and then we have higher order
derivatives
okay now uh
if indeed
our x equal to a
is a point of minimum then
this value f of a
it should be smaller than any of its
neighboring values
which means that
f of x minus f of a
should be greater than 0 there should
not be any doubt about it
okay so what i'm saying is that since f
of a is a minimum
anything else must be greater than 0
anything else must be greater than it
so f of x minus f of a must be greater
than zero
now you look at it this term
this is what we have here is x minus a
now depending on where our x is
it could be either to the left of a or
to the right of a
this x minus a by itself it can take on
a positive value sometimes it can take
on a negative value sometimes
now we do not want
this kind of a variability variability
of the value of
x minus a to influence
this value of f of x minus
f of a this is please note that this is
what we require
okay this is what we need
this is what we need to ensure
and just now what we said is that
depending
on where
x is located
x minus a
can be positive
or negative
now please note that since this
if you're if you're really interested in
the points which are very close by
a then x minus a is a very small
quantity
and then you can understand that x minus
a this value is going to dominate over x
minus a whole square so overall
as long as we don't have very
high values of these derivatives f dash
a f double dash a
as long as that is not so so we can
understand that
uh this term will be
larger than this term so this term is
going to dominate in value over this
term
so if this is sometimes positive
and sometimes it is negative what is
going to happen is that
we are going to end up with a situation
where f of x minus f of
a is sometimes greater than 0 and
sometimes smaller than 0
but that is some that is what we what we
don't need we don't need that
rather we want to ensure that f of x
minus
f of a is always greater than 0 so that
it is actually ensured that f of a is a
minimum
so there is a very subtle logic going on
here i hope all of you will be
able to appreciate it if you just think
about it for a minute
okay so this the the thing that that uh
that is crucial here is to appreciate
that depending on where
x is located x minus a can be negative
can be positive
or negative and because if we take a
uh if you take a value of x which is
very close to a
this is a very small value and then
square of that very small value is even
smaller
so this term is going to dominate over
this so overall this
term itself is going to influence the
sign of this f of x minus
f of a so we have to ensure we have to
ensure
that this kind of a variable value of x
minus a
is not playing any spoilsport how can we
ensure that we can ensure that
by switching off its influence as as
simple and straightforward as that
okay so
we want to ensure
that this
variable sign of
x minus a
does not influence
f of x minus f of a so very very subtle
logic here
okay and how can we ensure that so
we ensure that by requiring
that f dash a is equal to zero
so the trick is that if you switch off
this
thing we cannot switch off the value of
x minus a
it is going to have some value but we
can
require something on this so if we
require that f dash a is equal to 0
overall this variable sine of x minus
a is not going to influence f of x minus
f of a
so job is done and you note
that this exactly is the kind of
first step in our algorithm of finding
the extreme values of functions this is
what we do always we first always find
the first derivative
and set it equal to zero okay so this is
the prime
this is the fundamental motivation from
where it comes from
okay so i'm sure all of you know this
but it is good to
recap it again
next once we have ensured that
this is this is what we say is the
necessary condition okay
this is the necessary condition for
minimum
or maximum okay the same kind of
argument would follow for
maximization so this is a necessary
condition next
to actually ensure next
to ensure
that f of x
minus f of a is indeed greater than 0
and this is very easy to see you see you
you can you can note here
that x minus a whole square that is a
positive thing
this factorial 2 is of course positive
so all we have to do
is to say that f double dash a that has
to be greater than zero
we just require that
okay now as it turns out and we are not
going to delve into it
this is only a sufficient condition it's
not a necessary condition
if you want to delve more into it you
should go back and take a look at your
high school
math books your preliminary calculus
books
you'll understand why this is only
sufficient condition not a necessary
condition
uh okay so the subtle logic is present
here
okay and this is what we what we want to
this this is the logic which we want to
uh
export to our uh to our idea
of developing the method of
extremization of those
integrations that we were talking about
in the previous lecture
okay so uh let me write this down here
we are going to export this idea
this idea
extremization of the integrations
okay and that will do in the next part
of the lecture
thank you very much